In this problem, a truck stop along an interstate highway wants to replace a section of concrete slab.
The work is to be completed during a single overnight shift to minimize traffic impacts,
and the nightly minimum temperature is expected to stay above 45 degrees.
The compressive strength of the previous slab was 3,400 psi,
and the designers want to replace the slab with a mix of equal or greater strength.
What are the most likely materials to be included in the concrete mix?
Type 2 cement, chemical accelerator, coarse aggregate, and sand,
type 3 cement, chemical accelerator, sand and water,
type 3 cement, chemical accelerator, coarse aggregate, sand and water,
or type 5 cement, chemical accelerator, coarse aggregate, sand and water.
So here we have another conceptual problem. In this example, I will walk through how we can narrow down our answers,
even if we don't know a lot about construction or concrete.
I did not see any information in the reference manual about cement types,
so this problem is going to be focused on using a process of elimination to give us our best guess at the correct answer.
So the first thing we can see is that every single answer contains the terms chemical accelerator and sand,
so we can ignore them.
Next, three out of four of our answers contain water.
Then, three out of four of our answers contain coarse aggregate.
Two of the answers contain type 3 cement, while the others contain type 2 and type 5.
Now we can move on to using general knowledge, context clues, and process of elimination.
The slab being replaced is along an interstate facility, meaning it is expecting lots of traffic from heavy vehicles such as trucks,
as such we can pretty much guarantee that coarse aggregate is going to be required in the design.
This eliminates answer B.
Since nighttime temperatures are not below freezing, we cannot rule out the use of water in this design.
This doesn't completely eliminate A, but certainly helps if you have nothing else to go by.
Stopping at this level of guesswork could essentially lead you to a coin toss between two remaining answers.
At this point, I would be inclined to guess C, since it was one of two different answers to include a type 3 cement.
If we do have access to information about cement types, you will notice right away that type 3 cement has an a high early strength.
This would be important if the work needed to be completed during a single overnight shift, as is called out in the problem.
This would immediately reduce our answers to B and C.
From there, you would need to recognize that coarse aggregate would be a requirement for this type of design.
So in a lot of conceptual problems on the PE, there is no substitute for subject matter knowledge.
However, we can still narrow down our answers if we apply a process of elimination.